what is this what today I'm trying an
ombre lip is that what it's called you
just kind of apply it in the center
right if you have a second color no yes
no I don't know if it's a competition
but I want to win what oh my god I've
never actually like really used a selfie
stick oh I like this yeah oh okay apply
to the center of the lips and then
smudge that doesn't seem that hard ah I
can't oh man
eyes got my tooth okay yep hey wait wait
oh god this is terrible but I was
looking forward to doing this house it
is not oh dear oh god I can't use his
hands or I guess I could use it
nope that's not gonna work I'm too short
I don't even know what the point of the
smudger is okay we're gonna have to
hahaha the audio on this rollies him so
nice oh my god I look like a clown
ah it's in my mouth it's in is it it's
in my mouth
yeah looks great looks like I've been
making out with someone a little bit but
that's okay so I would give myself a
solid beat I think I did okay for what I
had going party
I just got it on mirror I think I just
ruined it oh wait oh so sorry
I think selfie sticks have one use and
this was not it this is weird this whole
thing is weird this trend is weird this
stick is weird everything is weird